l'événement musical à bercy tout à
l'heure avec sur la même scène les
ténors du rail rachita khaled desfaudais
la méga concert pour cette musique qui
s'adresse à un public de plus en plus
large
un spectacle baptisé 1 2 3 soleil
caroline laudrin à eric de l'agneau au
départ c'est un pari organiser un
concert avec trois grands noms du rail
comme avec les ténors du classique
les élus racheta khaled et faudel
détroit il est le plus jeune né en
france il a appris le rail avec sa grand
mère en algérie
petit faudel considérer khaled comme son
idole il ya cinq ans il chantait pour la
première fois ensemble
15 ans c'est même passer à la télé et
tout et j'étais fier quoi je chantais
dehors du marché dans ma cité j'étais
c'était content quoi je me suis dis bah
tiens et si si s'il ya des grands frères
comme ça inquiète l'ailé le petit frère
s'est bien racheté thalys étaient
remarqués en 85
il interprétait douce france de charles
trenet un message d'amertume mêlé
d'humour
né à oran il a grandi avec le rail il a
traversé les périodes techno punk
aujourd'hui ce serait plutôt du rock
teinté de rythmes orientaux
pour certains le concert de ces trois là
est un drôle de mariage et j'ai tendance
à diamant on n'a aucune affinité c'est
ça qui fait le leur mais l'intérêt de ce
spectacle c'est à dire que il ya trois
individus qui sont complètement
différents qui font quelque chose et qui
chacun apporte une pierre à l'édifice
pour la fête du rail il fallait bien ça
soixante huit musiciens dont les
célèbres vieux reng égyptien d'oum
kalsoum
quoi
ils chanteront seul à 2 à 3 ce sera leur
façon à eux de parler de l'algérie car
finalement une chanson mon bien à tous
les discours
une autre